- Oh my gosh.
- Hello.
- I feel like you could play Wonder Woman.
- You are just like this goddess.
- I appreciate that.
You walk in and you Yeah,
- thank you.
- Yeah, just saying goddess vibes.
- I appreciate it.
- It's okay.
I'm just saying what's happening.
Have y'all met before today?
- I saw him a couple days ago.
- We met very briefly
at a bar. At the bar.
At the SAG Awards.
- And I said, oh hey, nice to meet you.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna see you on Kelly Clarkson
in like a couple days.
- Yes.
- And he was like, whoa. Okay.
- Yeah, I was like how do you
know I'm on Kelly Clarkson
- in a couple days?
- Well.
- Cause when they do the pre-interviews,
I think they say.
- Yeah, yeah
But it's really nice to meet you.
- You as well.
- Just so you go, I'm
33, just so you know,
I'm 33 years old and all of your work
has affected my comedy profoundly.
- Aw, that's so lovely.
(audience applause)
- (Jessica) So it's very,
very nice to sit next to you.
- That's so nice. Thank you so much.
- It's an honor.
- I appreciate it.
- I've been watching
since like 16, 15, 16.
- That's so nice.
- Yeah. That's like ev, everyone.
You're hilarious.
Anyway, so you, you both,
this is interesting.
You both like to throw pottery
that's what they call it, right?
- Yeah.
- You throw pottery? -Yeah.
- You do pottery?
- Yeah, I be throwing it down. Yeah.
- I know, I didn't,
this is a random thing that we found
that you both have in common.
So when did you start doing it?
- I got into it, I used to
live in Brooklyn when I was
on the Daily Show for like 10 years.
And I'm from here.
But I got into it,
like I knew a breakup was happening
with this guy that I was
with for a long time.
And I was like, I need to
throw myself into a hobby.
- (Kelly) Yeah.
- (Jessica) And then it like happened
and then it just kind of took over
my life for a while and I really loved it.
It's very like therapeutic thing.
- (Kelly) It's like positive.
- (Seth) It is.
- (Jessica) And I haven't
done, I just moved back to LA
and I haven't done it in a long time.
So I need to find like a
- (Kelly) You're really good. Good.
- A place.
- Those are good.
- Yeah. They're, I got into it.
- Yeah, they're really good. Yeah.
- Thank you so much, that means a lot.
Now what I'm afraid
of is glazing and like
finishing the pieces.
Like that's the scariest part to me.
- Really?
- And something that I work
with my therapist Heather.
- Yeah, I was gonna say
- The follow through something.
- It means something.
- Yeah.
- Does that have to do with
the break up, the (laughs)
- Trauma,
There's a lot of trauma
worked into my art.
So
- You're like, if you finish
it, what does that mean?
- (Jessica) I don't know
if it will bring this
relationship back.
It'll come back haunting me.
Saying you up. Ya know, but
- (Kelly) That's, that's hilarious though.
- (Kelly) Cause I love quilting
but I love doing everything
up until the borders.
The very end part.
- (Jessica) Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- And because it's just
the hardest part to me.
_ (Jessica) It is. It is.
- Yeah.
- But I feel you're so
good at glazing too.
I mean, you're good at all.
- I took a glaze making workshop.
- (Jessica) Did you really?
- I make my own glazes.
- Do you?
- I do.
- See, I'm trying to get on that.
- Yeah. Oh, I, I'll give you some numbers.
- (Jessica) Yes.
- So wait, you play a therapist
on Shrinking a very funny one.
- Thank you.
- Tell us about the show.
- Thank you. Yeah.
So I play this character
named Gabby on Shrinking
which is on Apple TV.
And she works with Jimmy,
played by Jason Segel
and Paul, who's our boss,
played by Harrison Ford.
And Jimmy, Jimmy's character is grieving
because his wife suddenly passed away.
And I, I, they bought me onto the show.
It's done by Bill Lawrence
and Brett Goldstein of
like the lasso crew.
And they brought me on the show
cause they wanted my
character to really balance
out like Harrison Ford's, surliness
and then Jason's just
doing the Jason thing.
So they really wanted
they wanted her to come in
and balance everything out.
And you can see in that
office from that clip that
that she's very bright
and colorful and bubbly
and it's really fun cause I get to be
- (Kelly) Very funny.
- Yeah it's fun to be like this,
like bubbly, you know
millennial black lady like telling
saying "Panies" to Harrison Ford.
(laughter)
Like that rules.
- I'm sure he is heard that before.
- Is any of this (laughs)
- I mean he's heard it as panties.
Yeah. And then there's
like the black part of it, which is like,
oh, growing up like I didn't
know until I was older
that it's not panties, it's
panies like, it's like,
- (Kelly) Oh, I don't know. I'm Southern.
We say panies.
- (Jessica) Is it panties?
Right. But a lot of women go panties.
- Oh,
- Like panties. It's my panties.
Right, Seth?
- I call 'em my panties.
- I just love that people say panties.
It's a panties.
I say panties whatever.